here with more reaction Senate Judiciary
Chairman Lindsey Graham senator I don't
know I mean I think if I fluid China and
I had no experience in private equity
and I got a billion dollar a billion and
a half dollar deal I'd be pretty happy
but does it look good does it well you
know we've looked at the Trump family
and the Trump connections to rush every
way you can it's about time somebody
look at the connections of the Ukraine
here's my question when the vice
president told the Ukraine we will take
the money away from you unless you fire
the prosecutor did he have a conflict of
interest because the prosecutor was
looking at his son tomorrow when we read
the transcript is there any evidence at
all the President Trump threatened to
take a dawei from the Ukraine unless
they investigate Biden or do his
political bigots right here is no
senator what do you hear well I don't
know but I'll tell you this if the
answer is yes I'll be on your show very
disappointed with our president if the
answer is no this is Russia times two
times ten this do you see even just the
rush to judgment because we don't know
what's here we do know the inspector
general that Henry just broke the story
right the Inspector General yeah that
so-called whistleblower had a political
agenda they don't know any of the facts
they don't know any of the details now
if Donald Trump was gonna release his
transcripts with Ukraine and Ukrainian
president
I like the release of Joe Biden's
conversations with world leaders when he
was vice president and maybe Barack
Obama's as well is that fair yeah I
think it's very fair but I'd like to
know if the the whistleblower was not
part of the conversation
who told him or her about it well that
sounds like do you think somebody in the
deep state that will get you six ways
but suddenly according to Chuck Schumer
got him let me tell you somebody told
this person about a phone call that were
not part of did they have a political
agenda did the whistleblower have a bias
I'll make an offer to Nardone television
to the whistleblower if you want to
testify under oath to the Senate
Judiciary Committee you're welcome to do
so
because I want to find the truth and
here's another question was there a
reason to withhold aid to this new
Ukrainian administration until we knew
who they were and was it okay for
president Trump to withhold money to try
to get other countries to give more
these are the questions that somebody
needs to ask and answer senator is this
kind of politically speaking how do you
think this plays out for the Democrats
well it tells me that they think they're
going to lose at the ballot box the only
reason they're trying to impeach the
president discuss they don't believe
they can beat him at the ballot box or
they're trying to destroy him it comes
down to this if there's no evidence that
President Trump tried to coerce the
Ukrainians into investigating Biden and
withholding aid to the Ukrainian unless
they did
Trump's bidding against Biden then
there's nothing here that would be the
only thing that would bother me it was
the okay for the president to tell the
Ukrainians say if this prosecutor was
fired for a corrupt purpose maybe you
should look at it how do you get to a
point where a Democratic Party beyond
wanting open borders everything free
crazy new Green Deal Medicare for all 36
trillion dollars some estimates 94
trillion for the new Green Deal we only
take in four trillion a year they want
to stack the US Supreme Court they want
to get rid of the electoral college and
it seems that this party has lost any
sense of constitutional governance my
reading of the Constitution is the
enumerated powers of commander-in-chief
lie with the president how does the
president effectively be the
commander-in-chief if his phone calls
are being spied on and leaks are coming
out for people that have political
agendas and that this is second-hand
information where did it come from and
how is it that they got so much wrong
about it already well then yeah I think
what we want to know is the
whistleblower telling us something that
they know to be true firsthand are
they're repeating gossip given to them
by somebody else but here's what Trump
has done this so important you can read
it for yourself tomorrow the one thing
about this president that I admire in
this circumstance
he's releasing a phone call to a foreign
leader that you can make your own
judgement and if there is no evidence
that Donald Trump tried to intimidate
the Ukraine by withholding military aid
unless they investigated Biden there's
nothing here but there's a lot here when
it comes to Biden did he have a conflict
of interest when he threatened to
withhold aid to the Ukraine unless they
fired a prosecutor looking at his son
now that needs to be looked at was there
reason to withhold aid to the Ukraine
after this election apart from Biden a
lot of people in DoD were worried about
this new administration Sean should we
give them weapons because we don't know
how close they are to Russia let me ask
you this if if we're at a point here
where this is what we're gonna do is
we're now going to spy on presidents and
release it I really I don't know where
this all ends up senator is America less
safe tonight as a result of this America
is far less safe Weiner phone call
between the president the United States
and a foreign leader whistleblower files
complaint when they were not part of the
phone call America will be less safe if
there's two standards of justice in this
country if the Democratic vice president
can threaten to withhold aid to a
foreign country unless a prosecutors
fired who's looking at his son and
nothing happens and they're willing to
impeach President Trump on a phone call
they know nothing about that's dangerous
you have met can you give me any
scenario under which a vice president
United States is gonna hold out a
billion dollars I'm not gonna give it to
you unless you fire a Ukrainian
prosecutor walking Oh Emma that's unn
that's the better story to meet senator
real quickly what if Mike Pence calls
somebody tomorrow and threatened that
government with aid being withheld
unless you fired a prosecutor who was
looking at Mike Pence's sign do you
think that might make it in the news
well said Center thank you senator
Graham South Carolina with more